تركوا الحرب ورائهم بحثا عن طريق للخروج
من السودان الاف الاشخاص من عشرات
الجنسيات غادروا للوصول الى بر الامان
وعبر وجهات مختلفه كثيرون وجدوا ما تسنى
لهم من وسائل مغادره السودان بحرا او جوا
في حين لجا اخرون للطريق الاصعب بقطع
الجغرافيا السودانيه برا للدول المجاوره
مفوضيه شؤون اللاجئين في تشاد اعلنت ان
عشرين الف لاجئ وصلوا الى هذا البلد مع
توقعات بان يتبعهم مئه الف اخرون في اسوا
الحالات اما في جنوب السودان فترجح
التقديرات الامميه نزوح ما يصل الى 170
الف شخص ثلاثه ارباعهم من لاجئ جنوب
السودان الذين سيعودون في رحله نزوح جديده
لكن في بلدهم هذه المره حتى من وجدوا
دولهم او دوله ثالثه تمد لهم يد العون فهم
يعانون الامرين لمغادره السودان في رحله
محفوفه بالمشاق تليها نقاط توقف مؤقته لمن
غادروا برا الى مصر او جوا الى جيبوتي او
بحرا عبر بورسودان وصولا الى السعوديه
حسن غوليد العربيه لمتابعه
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات